je t'ai dit que c'était une femme et
tumorales influença j'étais donc achat
cekici tu sais qui sut boy sur moi
tant qu'on a envie on est tous sans
enjeu non ça ma part donc tu m'a permis
de rester en vie l'empereur c'est celui
qui tient tous les pouvoirs entre ses
mains politiques économiques médiatiques
l'image de la femme blessée qui se
relève tout le monde adore il n'y a pas
de règle absolue à 7 seulement des cas
particuliers
françois est parti mais moi je suis là
la famille aujourd'hui c'est moi c'est à
moi de m'en occuper
c'est un sale boulot seul voulons
enlever tout ça parce que personne
d'autre que madame edouard buffard
pendant un instant les envies ma vie
entre leurs mains ceux qui ont fait ça
doit fait me faut à ces mecs tu connais
le pari surtout en cas de récidive ça la
foutait là pas des couilles sur simple
appel depuis ce portable tout explose
n'aura rien tu n'auras rien tu n'a droit
à rien et on ne partage rien la porte
est ouverte si tu veux partir dégage tu
sors manenti 160 constructrice plus tu
changes ton avec moi je te prends
n'obéir naissent les cieux
personnes me disent que j'ai à faire
même pas toi ça nous décidâmes appelé à
100 tonnes personnes comment tu me
parles dans ma maison
j'aime pas la façon dont tu me parles tu
tiens tranquille et tu vas mois
j'ai envie de parec temps à une grosse
je fais pas les couples et pour 3000
vous feriez l'exception femmes c'est
quentin en bande réellement pour elle
dans mon couple va être compliqué c'est
moi après on visera je me ferai ma
rééducation nouvelle sera sandra son
doigt sandra ok on n'est ce pas je peux
boire quand même façon je préfère boire
que bézy
gauche la nature t'emmerde hier c'était
une petite d'allumeuse arrête
techip là tu te sens jouant manu j'ai
l'impression de sortir mon cousin
internet et trolleys et une merde mais
ces machines est toujours aussi dur
vaughters je trouve extrêmement gentille
au contraire